actually I feel like playing games today
do you like gaming Sean yeah I do
you know many computer scientists like
me got into computers in the first place
because we do like games and and we
think like okay I'm gonna go to
university I'm gonna learn how to
program and in no time I will be able to
do a very very cool game with visual
graphics and stuff like that really
that's the case but what I want to do in
this video today is to show you that
with a little bit of knowledge of
programming and using a library you can
do something very cool in Python that's
actually what I want to do I want to
start off actually showing the end
result of this video no it's actually
not the video but I'm gonna show you
again here to start with that my
students implement it recently so this
is again you can say zombie apocalypse
but they actually give you a bit of
instructions to begin with so that's my
friend towards them showing how the game
works
that's myself as well and I'm gonna
start playing oh and actually pretty bad
but I want to get this one because you
will say this one is super fun boom I
love my job
this is an example of what you can do
with Pi game which is the library I'm
gonna be using today but it's not
beginning I'm gonna be implementing
actually so my game is when I it's gonna
be way easier because we don't have time
to implement that kind of game but that
was done actually by a group of three
people working for a month worth of time
on the game for from people that didn't
have any experience programming before
so it's actually pretty cool isn't it
yeah yeah very good what we're gonna be
doing today is to play a very classic
game that everybody knows in computer
science which is the phone game actually
my very good friend Steve already showed
this game and actually use this game as
a good example to show what
object-oriented programming is right so
we're gonna actually rely on the concept
of object-oriented programming for for
this game so I want to show you very
quickly what the game is all about so
I'm gonna draw here how the screen will
look like so basically the idea is that
normally have a bubble about and you're
gonna have a bow and typically you're
gonna have actually a 2 players game in
which you have another puddle on the
other side and the idea is to is push
this bomb through so you win right so
that's the main thing but today I want
to play a slightly different game I want
to play a squash version of pong because
I don't have anyone else to play with so
I'm gonna remove this and what I want to
do is to basically draw three walls here
and the game that I want to implement
today with this library is basically
this in which this ball will go around
then will return back and I have to try
to catch it and not lose it right so
that's the main game I want to implement
to start with maybe later on we we add
more functionality right so to do so as
I said I want to use object-oriented
programming and I want to use also a
library what is a library gonna start
off with that a library is no more than
a collection of code that someone else
is actually implemented before rotate
and allows us to use it on their behalf
so those libraries are typically based
on object-oriented programming and they
have multiple classes multiple functions
that we can just simply import and news
and that library that we're gonna be
using is the one that we use in in our
course it is just one more library in
Python that allows you to play games it
allows you to put nice stuff on the
window and paint stuff on your computer
and also put some sounds is it the best
library if you ask me Sean well who
knows right it is relatively stable but
if you try what we're going to be doing
this video if you try to do this on a
Mac maybe you kind of disagree with me
on that one yeah but if you use Linux
like I'm doing here everything will be
fine so you know what I mean right so
you should be using Linux if you want to
anyways so this is a very good library
that allows you to do quite a few stuff
and and we're gonna be using
object-oriented programming how so
basically on the scenario that you have
you're gonna have a few things that are
let's say fixed right so you have the
green walls and
then you have the bubble and the bow and
these two objects will be actually be
moving on the screen and actually will
be interacting with each other right I'm
interacting with the scenario that we
have here so the bow will have to
collide at some point with the walls and
then returning back to the bubble right
so this is why we want to use
object-oriented programming because that
allows me and allows us basically to
create data types that have some sort of
function so basically we're gonna have a
ball and that ball is gonna be able to
be shown somewhere in the screen and to
update its position all around right and
the same thing with the public and the
paddle actually I want to control it
with my mouse so I want to be able to
move and update that position of the
paddle so I want you to think of how the
computer will be understanding the game
so basically the computer understand
about pixels and what we're gonna be
doing today is just painting we're gonna
be painting all the way so we're gonna
paint first as display and and then it
understands coordinate pick a pixel so
this point here it's actually coordinate
zero zero if this is actually the X and
this is the y-axis right so what is this
position it's the total of X and the
total of why isn't it so it depends how
big our court is let's say it's I'd know
500 comma 300 something like that
something like that exactly so what I'm
going to do actually is to be a good
programmer and I will actually define
that with a variable width and height
right so and then the actual number it
will depend on on this right so on the
values that we give to that and actually
this should be with and high minus 1 of
course right because we start counting
from 0 so that's the coordinate so the
way we're gonna be working with PI going
off with any other library whenever we
want to draw something on the screen you
need to tell it ok you need to go to
this point and draw that pixel right so
that's what we're gonna be doing today
the bowl what do you think are the main
important attributes of that
of that object what do you think is the
main thing well surely when it hits
something it has to rebound or balance
or something so we need to control
collision right that's something very
cool very important we're gonna be doing
that manually here but with actually
with pygame there is already some stuff
that can control collision and help you
doing that without doing it manually but
what do you think are the main
attributes so we have this object that
will be represented somewhere on the
screen so what we need to know about
that bomb is coordinates x and y right
so that's gonna be attributes and what
is the functionality of that ball is to
move around without colliding with
anything right and whenever it collides
just have to return so these are the
attributes and the functions and maybe
there is something more that we miss
which is how big we want this ball to be
right and that depends a bit on how
we're gonna be implementing this on
pygame the way that we are going to
implement this is with Cellcom and for
that you need to define the radius right
so if I were to define this with
object-oriented programming if we have
to define what the ball is I'm gonna
represent that in here I'm gonna need
coordinate x and y and I'm gonna need
definitely the radius what about the
color definitely that could be something
that we can put in as well the color
could be there if you want to and this
too variable could be if you want to
what we call class variables a class
variable will be always the same value
for all the balls that we draw right sir
actually I'm gonna draw just one single
ball but I might actually end up drawing
two different bubbles right in different
positions so these are the attributes
right what do you think we can do with
the ball let's say we want just to show
it right so we're gonna have
functionality to show it and we need to
be able to update the position to make
it move right so I'm going to call it
update that's why I call it in my code
I'm gonna be doing later on okay so do
we need anything else you think if you
want to start getting fancy into fancy
versions of pong maybe but I can't seem
you need to hide it in
to play harder ha ha ha we will see
where we do that yes we're going to be
doing that when we update yeah that's
actually a very good point um there is
something else for that
we will come back to this in a minute
right so what do you think we need for
the button so we've been out similar
isn't it I mean apart from it's probably
not going to be round so it won't take
radius it'll need like a cortex my kind
of size as well but what do I need for
that so what I need for that is
basically width and the height of that
particular puddle so it has nothing to
do with the height and the width of my
screen right it's something just
specific for the puddle right so that's
gonna be a class variable for for a
problem what do we need for my game for
for my game initially I stole you that
I'm gonna be playing this squash version
of it in which I only have one paddle so
the x-coordinate will remain actually
fixed but the y is the one I'm gonna be
moving especially with the mouse if
possible yes so we could if we want to
just simply represent Y I could put it
here should we put X initially I'm not
gonna be bothered because I just want to
do this game right so for now I'm gonna
say no maybe later on I will change my
mind in terms of functionality of that
particular object basically we want to
do the same thing we want to show it and
to update the position whenever we want
to right
the only difference is going to be how I
implement that update the ball will be
moving automatically the problem will be
controlled by the mouse or the keyboard
so it needs to be linked to the krafla
control rod so more exactly so here we
have now the ball and the paddle what we
think is initially a good definition of
how to represent these two objects right
so as I mentioned before what we're
gonna be doing whenever we play when
whenever we implement again on on a
computer is basically drawing stuff so I
want you to help me a bit of thinking
what are the different pixels to draw
the walls and to draw the paddle
initially and and let's try to
compute and calculate what the what the
coordinates of the different parts of
the game are right so in this screen
that you see on my iPad right now we
said here it's gonna be 0 0 for this
coordinate and I want to know how do we
draw this wall it's gonna depend a lot
on what the library offers you but I can
tell you I can anticipate that already
which is going to be basically a
function that allows you to draw a
rectangle right and then you need to
tell it the coordinate in which the
rectangle will begin and then you need
to tell it how big is the rectangle you
need to define width and height of that
rectangle so basically we need to tell
this we know from 0 0 2 with ya but then
we need to tell here what is this size
for the wall right so what we have here
is this width or the border of the wall
right so we need to define that as well
so that's gonna be another variable in
our program so we need to define how big
we want the walls to be and they should
be all of them the same so what do you
thing is the ordinates of this point
then highlighting here in red I think
we're gonna be going so X is the first
coordinate right so maybe it's 1,000
comma 5 or something like that it
depends on the screen resolution right
yes so this is a guess because you want
to do it for the resolution of your
screen right but so what I want to do is
to do it always relative right so we
want to do that on a variable that then
we set up depending on the size of your
screen so what you could do is to use
the variable width for that so you say
that the coordinate of that is gonna be
the with the maximum width and then this
number five value gave me five pixels
for the border so it is basically a
variable that we call border and now
we're gonna store there the pixels that
we want to use for them that could be
ten five thirty then we can play with
that whenever
the implementation itself right so the
point is this coordinate is in here all
right what is the position of the paddle
aha this one is probably the most
difficult one well it's it's not quite
at that so far across is it so it's the
width minus a bit let's say I want to
draw the battle yes next to the border
of the screen let's say right so this is
gonna be my button here so again if you
start drawing the paddle from a top left
like we did the rectangle you've just
got to take into account half the size
of the paddle as well there you go so we
we understand the position of the paddle
like this point here in the center right
but this is not quite how you actually
draw it whenever we want to implement
that we need to use what the library
actually offers you and the way we're
gonna have to draw this it's a bit
annoying because we need to tell this
coordinate here on the top left corner
is what Piegan or we'll use to draw this
rectangle here and then we need to say
this is here the width and this is the
height of our paddle so then you need to
compute this coordinate first to tell it
and then you say what is the width and
what is the height so this is half of
the total height minus half of the
paddles hi and then that's four for the
Y position and for the x position is yes
with the total width minus the width of
our paddle right so it's a bit tricky
you need to make a bit of thinking
whenever you're drawing a program right
so you need to think carefully okay
these are the tools that I have that the
library provides me and then I need to
come up with the position and how we're
going to be moving it so as you can see
it's actually not that straightforward
to do again right so basically that's
what I wanted to show you here in this
first video in which basically we just
draw what the game will look like we
have kind of defined what the ball
object will be in half and what the
paddle object will be and we'll have
might not be exactly the final version
of it we will see that whenever we start
implementing it there are a few tricks
that I
want to tell you but that's gonna be in
our next video in which we actually go
hands-on and we're gonna be implementing
the game live programming on Python yeah
start off by importing the library right
so if you're going to be using this you
need to install the library in your
computer right but whenever you have
done that you need to import PI again
and the very very first thing that you
need to program in this is the code we
write and how it modifies the data we
think rather